Wait,
where am I?
Wait mcgriddles log,
11 thanksgiving time when we celebrate
all where things were for a time for
family,
good food,
a time to relax with a good football
game and some beers.
The holiday can be traced to a feast in
16,
21 on Plymouth plantation in
Massachusetts was a good harvest year
due in part to the corn growing skills
taught to the settlers by squantum
pawtuxet into quote Edward winslow
would be not always so plentiful as it
was at this time with us.
Yet by the goodness of God,
we are so far from that we often wish
you partakers of our planet.
It's at this time of year that I'm often
reminded of Robert De Niro's great
comeback movie of 2009.
Everybody's fine.
No true,
true apartment and no
wait,
wait.
What the hell is this?
I just wanted to talk about.
You're saying that I can't talk about
Bobby [inaudible] great comeback role in
2009.
Oh,
so there's a bill in the House of
Representatives right now called the
Stop online piracy act or so.
Not many people know about it,
but those of us who have are Horcrux is
online.
You know that the Internet is and why
are they doing well?
It's because many of them believed that
this Bill Sopa,
which the house is very quickly and
quietly trying to push through to
passing,
represents an infringement on their
basic rights of free speech.
Let's take a minute to understand what
sofa is and how it works.
Private companies,
namely large corporations within the
entertainment industry,
the Motion Picture Association of
America,
the recording industry,
Association of America,
Netflix via content,
the ability to shut down on unauthorized
roque sites where people download tv
shows music and move.
Now,
they already have the right to do this
under American copyright law on an
individual basis.
You may have seen this screen before,
but a lot of these sites operating from
outside the US and so are in each
jurisdiction,
so we'll will allow the government to
force US Internet providers to block
access to domain names that carry this.
Con.
Corporations can also sue under so,
but any search engine that lists these
sites and their result or any blog
reform that provides the Linkedin,
but sofa has another.
This log is corporations and the
government,
the ability to choke the funding of
websites by forcing advertisers and
payment services,
pay pow,
mastercard,
visa from doing business with them from
the time the claim is filed,
the service would have five days to
separate the infringing website or risk
persecution.
What do you think payment service
providers will do given the choice?
It's economic submission and Internet
death panel.
Copyright Law is certainly in port
credit compensation should be provided
to artists who sell their work under
copyright.
They deserve to be protect.
The problem with sofas is that though
protection isn't stated aim,
the law won't be effective against
content piracy.
For example.
He'll still be able to access block
sites by entering the Ip address instead
of the domain,
but that's not all Sopa might actually
work against its purpose.
There's a thing you've never heard of
called the domain name system.
Security extensions or DNS SEC provides
end to end encryption of domain name.
Making sure that there's no break in the
chain between say citizens bank and its
customer,
forcing Internet providers to redirect
allegedly piratical sites to FBI servers
is incompatible with that.
Most experts believe that tampering with
the internets registry of domain names
will result in less security,
not more in fact is that hackers and
pirates have always had a way of binding
cracks and circumventing laws despite
efforts to stop what many fear about so,
but is its potential to curb and
discourage innovation in our most
innovative industry.
The digital marketplace of ideas that
welcomes every blog and tweet is the
same one that inspires the next
generation of innovators to fuel our
economy.
He will give corporations the ability to
target startups,
new search engines or new social media
platforms if they feel that they're
filtering isn't good at one lawsuit to a
small fledgling company is usually all
that it takes.
Even established sites like Tumblr,
youtube,
soundcloud,
and facebook could come under the gun.
Any amount of illegal content could be
enough to temporarily shut down the
entire site and violators.
That little baby who likes big.
Okay.
Or that guy who makes awesome acapella
that these
people could face jail time,
don't send babies to jail.
Representative Lamar Smith from Texas
announced the legislation last month and
it has bipartisan support.
Also has bipartisan opposition on this
issue.
Nancy Pelosi and Ron Paul are on the
same side.
Google,
facebook,
twitter,
Zynga,
Ebay,
Mazzola,
Yahoo,
aol,
and linkedin issued an open letter to
key members of Congress last week
stating that Sopa was a serious risk to
our industries.
Continue Track of innovation and job
creation as well as to our nation
cybersecurity,
and it should be noted that the MPA,
for example,
is a relatively tiny workforce.
When you compare it to the jobs created
by the inner.
I put links to petitions and information
on what representatives you can call in
the doodling.
Now,
there's a provision in American
copyright law called fair.
You get grants and exception to
copyrighted material for the purposes of
commentary,
criticism,
news reporting,
research.
Here are the four factors used to
determine whether or not use is fair.
The purpose and character of the use,
including whether such use is of a
commercial nature or is for nonprofit
educational purposes,
the nature of the copyrighted work,
the amount and substantial ability of
the portion used in relation to the
copyrighted work as a whole and the
effect or use upon the potential mark.
So what about my use of Robert De
Niro's?
Great comeback movie of 2009.
Everybody's fine.
Was it fair?
Okay.
One purpose and character.
Well,
I'm using the clip to make a point for
completely nonprofit purpose to the
nature of the work.
Well,
it's a Hollywood movie.
It's gross.
Sixty dollars million,
$454,850.
It's budget $20 million.
So I'm helping still on DVD.
Okay.
Number three,
the amount used.
Okay,
so I used 38 seconds.
Divide that by the run time of 99
minutes and you get my use of point
zero,
six,
three,
six percent.
Finally number four,
the effect on potential market.
Did you ever hear of this movie before?
I mentioned it still on DVD.
It's plain to see why fair use is
critically important in our way.
We are now a community of auto didact,
taking the best soup of information and
consolidating it into coherent stories.
This is how we learned today.
This is how we teach each other.
This is how we start a revolution or
take a stand or figure out where our
efforts can be put to the best.
This thanksgiving I'm grateful for.
Fair use.
Brought it full circle.
I'm also grateful for friends and family
and speaking of.
I have to get out of here.
Devin miscalculate.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's more like it.